winter sports fans have been hitting the
slopes at the Garmisch classic ski area
for almost 90 years now every year close
to a million visitors enjoy the 40
kilometres of ski runs down these three
mountains most stick to the snow on
store-bought skis and boards but a
little workshop in a
garmisch-partenkirchen suburb offers a
more personal alternative you don't have
to buy your skis in a shop here you can
custom build your own bending the edges
for their own skis this weekend our nine
men and one woman doctors teachers
students and an engineer move of
ahankhah it bends everywhere except
where I wanted to anyone can buy skis in
a shop but custom building your own is
great what you get depends on how much
effort you put into it if you do a bad
job you get a bad ski and if you put
lots of work into it you can get a
really good ski Florian Baumgartner is
one of the workshops co-founders the
idea came by chance and demand is 5 even
if nothing comes easy for the
do-it-yourselfers once everything's been
sanded down and the surfaces are
completely finished they begin to
realize what they've just spent two days
doing those are all the individual parts
that have to be prepared and then
tomorrow they'll be holding the finished
product then you'll see their eyes open
wide for now though their eyes are
focused on the design
the graphic aspect is an important one
but a question of individual taste
I think it'll end up too busy if you
start laying purple peacock feathers in
and my experience that never looks good
but this way it looks great let's look
at version number one cambering only and
no active rocker now it's a matter of
tuning the skis performance the
cambering or arching has to be carefully
adjusted then layer four layer of
fiberglass mats are glued to the core
with the top sheet coming last the
layers are not pressed together in
pre-manufactured molds like they are for
factory made skis here a foil is drawn
out in a vacuum and the ski is laminated
and baked in a special oven
the odds of hidden since we set the
shape length and camber in each pair for
each customer individually we'd have to
make new moulds for every one that would
drive the prices sky-high so we work
with a vacuum because the vacuum sac
stretches out evenly over the whole ski
the skis have been cured in the oven now
there's one last step left for the next
morning
they cut out the profiles sand them down
and then spit them up
once a person has made a pair of skis
with their own hands they tend to hold
out of them
at last the time has come to try them
out the skis are presented inside the
shop but the skis have to dry thoroughly
before their owner can strap them on and
take off now comes a long tedious wait
before I can finally try them out next
weekend but I'm glad I made them this
exceeded all my expectations